[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof hello Walter hi Martin
we're talking
we're continuing well we actually
thought that it uh it would be too but
it turned out to be three right yes
because the climate cop 27 is actually
two weeks full of everything and there's
a lot happening so we can't
brush aside some of the things that had
that did happen all right so we need to
talk about these things and uh
hopefully Martin
they will get on with it because really
this is becoming a good word would be
nauseating and what also happened is
that a lot of people were well there was
an expectancy building up now towards
this and everybody thought oh wow so now
this is going to be news is going to be
this new Commandments that's been set
out there especially people that are
waiting for prophetic fulfillment now
the interesting thing is the devil never
works like that exactly because he
always comes via a back door he's not a
front door man he's a Backdoor Man so
that's why you have to when these things
happen go and see in the back what's
happening behind the scenes exactly
exactly that's pretty much it's open
with a word of Prayer
a Heavenly Father
it's a privilege to work for you and to
be ask that you please once again
Enlighten our minds and to guide this
discussion in Jesus name amen amen
but
before we start yes there's an
announcement that we'd like to make oh
yes
we have recorded a special program which
we are working on which we want to
release in the WhatsApp Prof slot
from the 22nd of December till the 12th
of January and then we will continue
with the normal WhatsApp Prof Series so
we're working on it and trying to get it
ready
and by God's grace we will have it ready
yes and it's an exciting one so people
must not miss yeah it's the same it's
the same it's the same but it's like a
little bit different and some of the
faces might change yeah but uh we'll
come back to the original format after
that so I hope people will get a
blessing out of it
so let's Dive Right into this now while
we're talking about climate repentance
climate religions and 10 climate
Commandments which of course are
uh necessarily vague
because that's how it works out of
vagueness behind the scenes comes
something totally different it's also
if you read the portion in the spirit of
Prophecy the Sunday law is making its
way in dark in darkness in other words
in secret exactly
a lot of things happening but the main
thing is happening behind the door
well Martin our first one comes from a
Jesuit source
they are Relentless in their Pursuit
they're probably sitting behind all of
this in any case yes they're keeping the
door closed so that you can't see what's
happening behind it but they're so
excited about what they're doing that
they can't keep their mouths shut right
every now and then something slips out
so the Jesuit review Pope Francis calls
on Christians to repent and modify our
lifestyles to save the planet
you know he should ask nature to repent
as well because as we said in the last
one one volcano just the one that
recently uh exploded there or put
emissions into the sky in Iceland
produced more CO2 than all Humanity to
combined could produce in four years so
one little volcanic eruption and there
are thousands Martin
will set you back four years so I'm
wondering whether he takes nature into
account when he talks about nature but
that's not part of his agenda no so the
ends justify the means so what are the
means that they are using to justify the
ends
now if you take what we've also said in
the previous episode
this repentance you repent towards Jesus
for sins that you commit yes you don't
repent towards nature it's paganism at
the worst level exactly and that we've
seen in that the portion of that letter
brother son they're actually repenting
towards Mother Earth yes which is
totally Pagan like it just said
it's pathetic
so in his message for the world day of
prayer for creation the pope said the
current climate crisis is a call for men
and women especially Christians
you know Martin it irritates me that
they always put in and especially
something is always especially for some
Target group why aren't we just all
Humanity why must you isolate one
portion of humanity to the detriment of
others
if if a catastrophe strikes it is not
selective it is not selective it strikes
the rich it strikes the poor it strikes
the strikes all the ethnic groups we all
suffer as a collective Humanity but this
nonsense of especially taking out one
group is absolutely horrendous in my
opinion it's a plan actually it's a
think about it because they are the same
people not in only him but everybody
that shouts Against Racism or all of
this they actually are doing the same by
doing this so what is he saying by
saying especially Christians he's saying
that is the group that is not playing
ball that is the little group that must
come into line that is what he's saying
by saying that or when he says the poor
or when they talk about ethnicity or
whatever you know you have black lives
matter and uh Kanye West yeah no white
lives matter there was a huge Forum
about what about all lives matter
you know this target grouping is to put
you on a guilt trip it's true so but
they will they will use guilt trips for
as long as they can get mileage out of
them it doesn't matter what it is
but if you take it
Israel had the same problem
they will also and look where it got
them your house has left you desolate
let's live desolate and it works like
that in the political sphere I don't
want to go into politics but let's take
apartheid for example
I grew up in the apartheid era I was on
both sides of the Divide because I'm an
old goat right
but these young children that are born
now that have been born in the last
generation
they had nothing to do with it but they
still bear the blame on both sides of
the divide the one is suffering and the
other one is this and the yet and the
other and you have all kinds of laws you
know what when can we finally realize
that by one blood he created all of
humanity and the question is not do you
belong to a ethnic group do you belong
to a particular
religious system do you do this do you
do that but the question is when will we
realize
that Sinners come into the world and
that the problem is sin
that's the problem the basis that
problem behind everything that is the
cause we're just treating symptoms the
whole time now which religion
tells us what the cause of the issue is
but provides the solution as well
Christianity only Christianity provides
that solution therefore Christianity
must be a Target
and the one who provides the solution
must be marginalized because the others
do not want to accept the solution yes
yes that's what it is
so Martin even if you are a Christian
there are thousands of groups within
Christianity and even if you finally
belong to the remnant there are
thousands of groups within the remnant
and no matter what issue you touch
whether it be diet or whether it be
issues of Salvation never too will seem
to agree on an issue
it's true and it's a sad thing because
we have to get Unity yes
so we must repent and modify our
lifestyles and destructive systems
so that sounds to me like build back
better no for sure yes
I think it's built back better
but Francis said the vaticans July 6
accession and they always use this this
terminology like you said previously
this is biblical terminology yes they
are Kings they have their accession they
have climbed upon the throne
in the UN framework convention on
climate change and the Paris agreement
was made in the hope quote that Humanity
of the 21st century will be remembered
for having generously shouldered its
grave responsibilities who's making this
appeal as the one who has had the
accession who's become the king the
kings of the world will give their power
unto the Beast
underlying all this the pope wrote there
is a need for a covenant between human
beings and the environment we have a
covenant with God I don't need a
covenant with anyone else exactly
because the Covenant means two
intelligent parties make a Concord with
each other I cannot make a intelligent
Concord with the environment yeah
because it cannot speak it doesn't have
ears it cannot talk it cannot see it
cannot hear
so this is total paganism at its worst
which for us Believers is a mirror
reflecting the creative love of God so
they twist it to bring in a pantheistic
entity but he's marginalized because
you're not talking to the environment
exactly and we've got a biblical term
here as well mirror reflecting creative
love of God what is the mirror of the
Bible that Commandments well so now they
want to change this let's have a look
from whom we come and towards whom we
are journeying
are journeying whose journeying
now when you Journey Martin are you on a
road yes can there be a narrow road on a
broad Road yes now what does the Bible
say the majority is on the narrow road
right no oh
the majority is on what road on the
broad so let's watch how we journey
right all right
obviously we're not on the same page as
the Jesuits right no
all right here's another article from
the tablet 15 November 2022 Vatican
tells
but I don't really have to go much
further what do you say about that
Vatican tells cop 27 the wound that is
supposed or is going to be healed
means that the Beast will get his
political power back
and this seems to me that the headlines
these days
as if the wound is basically healed now
what if it said the Martin Smith tells
cop 27.
would there be any reaction whatsoever
no no none whatsoever right or while the
fight tells cop 27 no
Vatican tells cop 27 that climate action
can no longer be postponed they tell
that to the volcano that erupted in
Iceland yeah but you see the Covenant
with nature was not in place then I see
so I believe nature will respond the
pope also promoted the lodato C action
platform which was set up to consolidate
efforts to implement
the Pub's 2015 encyclical on the care of
our common home modern are they
absolutely adamant that he is laudato C
must be implemented yes
so everything that's written in there
that he
propagate propagates to combat this
climate change they want to implement it
and obviously we've mentioned it many
times before there's a certain law in
there that we that will be implemented
eventually a certain day yes I encourage
this crucial mission for the future of
humanity so that it may Foster in
everyone a concrete commitment to care
for creation he said
the form the letter which we've spoken
about
has been shown twice at cop 27.
Martin
we haven't shown it twice but we had two
episodes
hosted by the government of Senegal the
Holy See and the lodato Sea movement the
documentary is devoted to protecting and
saving our common home
someone this is what is happening and we
just want to make it absolutely clear to
the people that you cannot divorce and
separate the Vatican from the issues
that are taking place not at all so who
is the Beast
the Roman Catholics Roman Catholic
system whether we like it or not and now
you've got another thing that you have
to realize
probably well 90 percent of the
population of the Earth
don't know this is happening yes so just
because it is it doesn't seem to be a
prominent news article all of this
doesn't mean it is exactly what is
prophecy being fulfilled yes
all right Breitbart also November 2022.
Pope Francis threatens climate crisis
while decrying prophets of Doom
I see he's wearing green
so he's become a greeny is he Kermit
the pub sent out a series of mixed
messages in his yearly homily for the
world day of the poor
again you are isolating a group you know
sin
does it only affect the poor no
does it affect the rich as well yeah are
there many rich people in jail these
days no only a select few that they want
to make an example of while those
thousands that molested those 260
000 children are scot-free right
okay so selected groups spreading
intense fear of possible climate change
disasters yet cautioning against
prophets of Doom the Sirens of populism
and self-interested false Messiahs
let us light candles of Hope in the
midst of Darkness the Pont of
urged you know Martin when it comes to
these things like their little rituals
and their little light ceremonies and
their candle ceremonies I think it was
Latimer that said to master Ridley when
they were going to be
burnt at the stake for what they did
he said you know instead of propagating
the light of the world the papacy will
propagate candles
down with the word and up with the
candles yes so here we go we're still in
the same issue so they light the candle
and the light of the world and thy word
is a lamp unto my feet that is
extinguished and if you guys if you take
the celebration of Diwali
Festival of Lights yes it's all all
candles and lights but that light of the
world is nowhere to be seen it's nowhere
a dramatic situations let us seize
opportunities to Bear witness to the
gospel of joy and to build the Fraternal
world or at least a bit more fraternal
but that's a contradiction in terms
because that's a compromise with what
the Bible condemns
in his 2021 message for the launching of
the United Nations decade on ecosystem
restoration Francis insisted that the
current environmental situation calls us
to act now with urgency
we have tenures
Martin is he a prophet
well or he knows something
ah maybe he knows a timeline after all
he must be in communion with his boss
right
so he has 10 years to restore the
ecosystem which will mean the integral
restoration of our relations with nature
this past week was replete with warnings
from prophets of Doom during the UN cup
27 climate Summit on charm El Sheikh
Egypt but who are these prophets of Doom
well I think we will probably qualify
qualify anybody who doesn't agree with
this procedure or sees the Pagan
elements in it must be a prophet of Doom
right yeah
but let's just go to the guardian and
we'll see what they are saying over here
this is the United Nations this is
another very reputable Source in the
world today so they think
world is on highway to climate hell U.N
Chief warns at cop 27 Summit
so good arrest told world leaders at the
opening of the cop 27 duet climate
Summit in Egypt on Monday we are in the
fight of our lives and we are losing and
our planet is fast approaching tipping
points that will make climate chaos
irreversible we're on a highway to
climate hell
with our foot on the accelerator well
you know the rock band sang that
we're on a highway to hell yeah we and
the world celebrated and how many drum
sets did they have bashing that song out
at their Gatherings God remember we've
even showed this is off topic again but
that it's even in cartoons in in
animation films for kids but yeah that's
correct okay so we know that the world
is on a Highway to Hell because the
Bible says so that's it
so we can sign a climate solidarity pact
or a collective suicide pact he added
you know I was just thinking now that
this is so
hilarious actually
because the Bible is telling us we're on
our way to hell oh I wait till on a
highway to climate hell with the plagues
that will be falling and this is
Humanity's
push to try and block that yes let's see
how successful they are
so Abdel fatah al-sisi the president of
Egypt said in his opening address to the
summit that poor and vulnerable people
around the world were already
experiencing the effect of extreme
weather
it's amazing only the poor and the
vulnerable experience nobody else does
so obviously it must be very selective
this is a very wise climate change
the intensity and frequency of climate
disasters has never been higher in all
four corners of the world bringing wave
of the wave of suffering for billions of
people is it not high time today to put
an end to the suffering
it Riles me up because they're using
things to push their agenda yes and
they're using emotional language that's
it because now people that talk against
this like us
seem insensitive yes towards people that
that are suffering as a consequence of a
flood or disaster but that's not the
case the thing is they are using that to
push an agenda
for climate change what do you have to
do to fight climate change and then
comes the laws all right you might as
well say martin that cancer is ravaging
the world especially the vulnerable and
the poor
uh is that would that be a true
statement No it would not be true it's
only that it seems that it's worse there
because they don't have any means so if
you want to gain sympathy you make a
statement like this this Falls in
exactly the same category
or motor accidents affect largely the
poor would that be true no now let's
look again at what Vatican news has to
say Pope encourages cop 27 first he told
them no encourages them recalls laudato
C action platform University basically
what we are showing is no matter what
you do you come back to his letter
so the pope also called the lodato C
action platform which was set up to
consolidate efforts to implement the
Pope's 2015 encyclical on the care of
our common home so just to make
absolutely sure does the Vatican have an
agenda oh definitely
and in Years Gone by like in the Middle
Ages they if the pope said this he
didn't say it
so calmly it was a command and then it
had to be done but now it's just more
subtle but it's still a command it's
still exactly the same thing
so
we are showing a prophetic fulfillment
is it happening different
is he asking the kings of the world to
give their power to his encyclical
if you you can read it how can you not
see this are the kings of the world
sitting on Mount Sinai willing to give
him that Authority and that recognition
yes you can just have a look at Kerry
and Xi Jinping he's actually they're all
part of this so
basically we can rest our case right
all right here's earthbeat a project of
National Catholic Reporter Earth big
these are all from November
of this year as crop 27 talks store
Catholic smash tablets pray for divine
intervention on Sinai button they don't
have to smash the tablets they've
smashed them already we just have to
read the catechism of the Catholic
church and you'll see that they've
smashed them to Smithereens they're just
in acting it symbolically that's
so this is rather important and we'll
have to look at it in a little bit more
detail as Dawn broke on the site where
the Ten Commandments are believed to
have been delivered to Moses
hundreds of Catholics led by dozens of
priests knelt before the foot of the
mountain
they prayed for world leaders at cop 27
to submit to God's will
whose will God's will I thought it was
the Pub's world because he wants to
implement his encyclical right so
thousands of Catholics are praying that
laudatusi will be implemented
that's God's will according to them
and fully commit to fighting climate
change earlier that morning climate
activists smashed MOX tablets of stone
Atop The Mountain in reaction to world
leaders failure
to follow through on commitments to
mitigate and adapt to climate change the
ACT referenced the story in Exodus 32
when after descending Mount Sinai and
angry Moses smashed the Ten Commandments
in protest against the Israelites
worshiping other gods now if they had
the spirit of Prophecy they could read
there that it was not a sin that Moses
committed it was basically a symbolic
act of showing that the Commandments had
been broken
Mount Sinai is a sacred place
modern is that so no no something is
sacred only of the presence of God is
there yes but when you have a pagan
ritual on top of it then you can be sure
that God is not involved except as an
observer
so Mount Sinai is the sacred place and
our presence here is in search of
communion with God who hears the Cry of
the poor
said father Len and Chetty a member of
the Society of Jesus in southern Africa
so there we have another Jesuit modern
so if you have any riches please don't
pray because he won't hear you
this is Again The Selective language to
create sympathy
we need those cries again and to be
remissioned by the god of Joseph and
Moses is that true Martin
no it's not true because we've got our
mission already we have our marching
orders and our marching orders cannot be
changed and neither can our Commandments
be changed no
damage Spruce Head of the advocacy of
Caritas Australia said the visit and
prayers at Mount Sinai could convert the
hearts of world leaders before the U.N
climate convening is scheduled to end on
Friday
so who must accept the slave of
propaganda the leaders of the world yes
and then it must be put through to all
Humanity okay is that a fulfillment of
Prophecy that the powers must give their
power unto the Beast who is doing the
asking who do we read here is doing the
asking or the informing then church
correct so let's have a look at it from
another perspective The Times of Israel
activists smash tablets atop Mount Sinai
to launch faith-based climate push
so an initiative to mobilize Faith
leaders worldwide to push governments to
do more about climate change kicked off
Sunday morning with an Israeli
environmental activist smashing mock
tablets of stone atop an Egyptian Peak
believed by many to be Mount Sinai to
symbolize the world's failure to protect
the planet
now if you look at those tablets they
were green right they were green funny
Stones they must be full of moss
the Sinai climate partnership
symbolically launched at the ceremony
brings together the Interfaith Center
for sustainable development
the Elijah Interfaith Institute the
names are fascinating to me
everything that they are talking about
like Elijah has absolutely nothing to do
with what is going on here the Peace
Department the United Nations faith for
the Earth initiative
a brahmovitz's gigawatt Global button
what do these names signify
that it's from all it's business and
faith and all coming together and the
Israeli environmental advocacy
organizations Martin couldn't they have
chosen longer terminology
you were saying that Elijah's got
nothing to do with it but maybe this is
another Mount Carmel situation
yes but it's not Mount Sinai it's a
Mount Carmel yes
after the group read from a new draft of
the ten principles for climate
repentance
formulated by dozens of multi-faith
leaders this is very important
this is a collective action
meeting in London over the past few days
abramovitz's smatched two tablets on the
ground
today as Faith put aside their
differences in a common call for climate
action because they cannot agree on
actions of salvation
we work towards a New Covenant for
mankind
Martin what's wrong with the old one
that Christ made with Humanity the
problem is mankind couldn't keep it
uh-huh
why couldn't they keep it Martin
because they couldn't submit to Christ
they couldn't take him as they all and
everything all it took was to open the
door no they'd rather have this door
because it's easier for them right
so that when the New Covenant for
mankind what did you want to say I was
just thinking when we did that one on
the covenants if you think who was the
one that every time initiated the
Covenant God
who is initiating it yeah the pope
can it work no
especially not for me no
so there was a New Covenant for mankind
in the name of the protection of our
common home I thought the Covenant that
God made was to deal with the sin
questions
this is a totally new covenant
and for the betterment of our shared
human future what does the Bible say
it's going to get better or it's going
to get worse worse and it's going to end
um so Martin
we have two totally different covenants
two totally different mindsets
so here is the Elijah Interfaith
Institute YouTube channel let's have a
look how they depict what happened at
Mount Sinai
[Music]
I grew for about 50 World religious
leaders has been working on these
spiritual principles for climate
repentance we're going to enter this in
a prayerful spirit so we're going to do
is the following we will be led by
sounds silence and our
after that this time to talk and to
share but we're going to start by
having a moment of silence
then we're going to sound The Conch
conch is a Hindu sign of auspiciousness
blessing beginning we'll begin with the
Conch then the Bell will sound between
each of the ten principles to be read
from the Scrolls that everyone is
holding in his hand
and Bell after each principle moment of
silence for all those gathered here even
if you didn't know you're capable of
being silent you're going to learn that
today
and then after that moment of silence
the bell will ring again the next
principle we read until we get to the
end and then we conclude with the sound
of the shofar which is the analogous to
the
to The Conch uh sound produced from a
natural from a Ram's Horn which in
Jewish tradition is a call for
repentance and therefore we conclude
this part of the repentance ceremony
with the sound of the shofar
call to action
and a quarter return
to a true vision of the creation
the Creator
and the harmonious relationship of
humanity with creation
therefore
use sort
speech and action only for the good
therefore act knowing that every action
counts
foreign
I hope God heard all of those things
because maybe he was sleeping
maybe he was on a little journey
somewhere
we don't have to go through the entire
list that Elijah mentioned but uh
you know I just thought
if you got to look for example
and you turn to Luke chapter 20.
where
from verse 45 Jesus says the following
and it's interesting then in the
audience of all the people
he said unto his disciples
so this is something that Jesus wanted
everyone to hear because it says in the
audience of all the people
he said unto his disciples Beware of the
scribes which desire to walk in Long
robes and love greetings in the markets
and in the highest seats in the
synagogues and the chief rooms of the
feasts which devour widows houses and
for a show make long prayers
the same shall receive greater damnation
it's a terrible verse to quote under
these circumstances
but Pomp and ceremony has always been
part of paganism
humble prayer and submission to God is
out of fashion modern
it is true
this isn't
if you take the whole story of Elijah
I
that was many much different than what
we've just seen it's it's exactly the
same thing so from this announcement
these various leaders of these various
movements with the very long integral
names
then representing this issue went to the
top of the map let's see what happened
there
welcome to the summit of Mount Sinai I
Am David Miller Wapner chair of the
Interfaith Center for sustainable
development we have ascended the
mountain on behalf of our partners in
the Sinai climate partnership the Peace
Department led by James sternler the
Elijah Interfaith Institute and the
direction of Rabbi Elon Goshen gotstein
Facebook the faith for Earth initiative
of the United Nations environment
program
and the Israel Union of environmental
defense and the Roseburg Foundation from
Canada and the international
program who we have met up here on Mount
Sinai
we are here at Mount Sinai a place of
historic Revelation a holy spot there
are three abrahamic faiths at the same
time the world's political and Civil
Society leaders gather south of here at
charmelechef for the unfcc cop 27. we're
here to kick off a global spiritual call
to action on climate Justice with being
held at 10 different mountaintops around
the world
culminating in the first of its kind
ceremony of repentance for climate
Justice in London later on today
so um
these tablets already a little bit
broken they were they were made by the
strike for Friday's teenagers and then
Hebert says keep your promises which are
not being kept by the world leaders
the whole world needs to cut our
emissions by half by 2030.
and they're not yet
we take these green Commandments
we look down to charmele Sheikh
and we're not satisfied
[Music]
while Martin not only on that mountain
but on 10 mountains
could we say those are high places
I was thinking the same thing
so they're having their little
ceremonies on all the high places now
why 10 Martin because there's Ten
Commandments there's Ten Commandments
and ten regions of the world ten seems
to be a very important number
so Martin what are all these principles
that they are talking about let's just
look at them and this year comes from
climate repentance.com
now Martin
repentance from sin has moved to
repentance from climate
this is how a ridiculous it's gotten
it's it's that and it's not a little
subliminal movement no it's massive
so the ten spiritual principles for
climate repentance
God and the world the nature of being we
recognize human responsibility to love
and protect nature we must treat all of
life with reverence Martin why do they
have selective groups then
we must care for each other and the
planet
now and this all sounds fine
so
you know it's a morsel that people will
be able to consume
then humanity and its responsibilities
commitment to not harm creation and the
responsibility to protect it commitment
to serve advance and Aid the growth and
evolution of all parts of creation
Martin can you agree with that one no no
no
what's wrong with you
a disciplined spiritual life is helpful
in overcoming the challenges of climate
change
use thought speech and action only for
the good
well
with the Fallen nature and without
Christ let's see how far we get
the human person is benefited by the
ongoing effort to purify raise and
transform himself
in view of a higher Vision Martin is
that possible in terms of Christianity
not without God no
to transform himself this is new age to
the team
living in spirituality and
responsibility
modern you can be very spiritual and
still have no faith in the god of the
Bible
act knowing that every action counts we
adopt a Mindful and attentive view of
the natural world be sensitive to the
Intolerable insecurities and injustices
in which so many of our fellow humans
live that is the sentimental cord
so
Guidestones that have been
removed by explosive means
also smashed or something so there were
also symbolically smashed right
but they've actually been replaced
and they're still there
because RC Christian
who apparently wrote it is very active
on Mount Sinai the Roman Catholic Church
as we have seen is very active the RC
Christian on Sinai so what did the
Georgia Guidestones say maintain
Humanity under 500 million In Perpetual
balance with nature
so the other seven and a half billion
must stop breathing because they're
contributing CO2 yeah so actually the
first one year in the Guidestones is
also related to climate it's related
guide reproduction wisely improving
Fitness and diversity
so again you have an interference with
God's plan that said multiply that's it
don't the climate activists have the
same thing going they're saying that the
who's the problem humanity is a problem
because we're overpopulated in all of
this yes unite Humanity with a living
new language who separated the languages
God who wants to bring them together the
devil the devil but
what is the new language
it's already there climate change
climate climate
rule passion Faith tradition and all
things with tempered reason
informed by faith or faith informed by
reason just we're thinking we've
discussed that on many many occasions
this is a Jesuit document
protect people and nations with Fair
laws and just courts well Martin if they
succeed in doing that on this Earth
then I will be more than slightly
surprised
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
Court that's asking for One World
Government
avoid Petty laws and useless officials
well start with yourselves well if you
just want to go to number six again so
what is cop and United Nations it's
actually doing that already
disputes resolving disputes in a world
court or this but it's not a world it's
not a court
but that's what they're trying to do
with cop and this get all the disputes
together for one deciding organization
that decides not only your morality but
your actions as well makes me think of
the World Health Organization don't even
go there Martin
balance personal rights with social
duties
prize well this is pure climate change
that's it
prize truth beauty love seeking harmony
with the infinite Martin
you shall have no other gods besides me
and do not be like the pagans
who think they will be heard because of
their repetitive prayers well if you
take there it's also infinite what about
the mother earth situation that you've
got now so you have to get in Harmony
and beauty and love with Mother Earth
and be not a cancer on the earth leave
room for nature leave room for nature is
this climate change it's the same thing
it's the same thing so the Georgia
Guidestones have been replaced by a new
set of rules so let's have a look what
BBC News has to say Georgia Guidestones
American Stonehenge demolished after a
blast
well it seems to be a lot of symbolism
involved so I wonder who blew them up
has there been any prosecution no no so
whoever blew them up is not a problem
so it must be part of the solution you
see we've I think we mentioned this
before you've got a few
aspects going here
people it could have been blown up to
get more attention towards it
and it could have and now you've got the
other side who are glad it's blown up
but they still it's like we've just
mentioned it's going still forward in
just another in another form and totally
another form
all right Martin so we see that there
really isn't much difference in the
sentiment of the documents that they
have produced
but the fact is they wrote them on two
tablets
and they were green
so they are new
there are new criteria for Humanity
which the Georgia guidestone says all
Humanity for the sake of social cohesion
should comply with
make room for nature make room for
nature is how they end
so it's the same sort of sentiment the
same driving force
and we can be pretty sure that the
Jesuits have their finger in the pie
so Martin when it comes to the culling
of humanity
irrespective of what means are used for
reaching that goal and whether they want
to introduce Noah height laws and all of
these things let's wait for the future
to unfold before we say anything more
about that now Martin what we really
have to talk about
is the contrast
between these laws that they have
created which are very vague yes they're
very vague and very specific laws that
God gave on Mount Sinai how does God
feel about his law
it's that's so important
and just to bring in as well remember
these laws have ensconced in it maybe in
darkness
something that will be implemented let
me get to that Martin I think if we want
to know how God feels about his law it
might be a good idea
to go to the psalm that was written
with these laws of God specifically
and of course I'm referring to the
longest Psalm in the Bible
isn't that amazing yes
the longest Psalms in the Bible the one
that that deals with the law of God is
the longest in the Bible correct
and I don't want to go through the whole
thing
but we certainly can highlight a few
thoughts out of it
because number one when you read psalms
119.
and you think that there are religious
systems that will take such a Sublime
concept as we as we have here
and say that it has been done away with
there is like saying that the most
precious thing that God has on which is
government is based has been done away
with
God has decided that his law is useless
after singing the most Sublime song
in its favor
it is so ridiculous
so if we read it then we must bear in
mind that it also has Messianic
overtones
because the embodiment of the law we
find that in an individual in Jesus
Christ
and I know we've been a little bit
facetious and even sarcastic
but let me justify by saying Elijah did
the same on Mount Carmel when it came to
the truth that's it we're not supposed
to be sarcastic when it comes to people
and individual where you hurt individual
feelings but when it comes to nonsense
like this
then you really have to distance
yourself from it and I would like to say
any organization
that willingly takes part in these
rituals is taking part in a pagan ritual
and honoring the god of ekron and not
the god of the Bible irrespective of
what religious system come it comes from
even from our own
it shows a complete lack of
understanding of the difference between
paganism and the worship of the true God
that's true and everybody that's
affected by this or let's say
indoctrinated
we feel sorry for them yes just as we
want the also God help them but how many
Israelites
were on the bail side of the issue on
Mount Karla the majority the majority so
we can expect that there will be maybe
even the majority that has swallowed
this nonsense hook line and sinker so
let us not right off the system because
after Elijah had done his work
they did say the true God is the god of
the Bible
so blessed are the undefiled in the way
who walk in the law of the Lord blessed
are they that keep his testimonies and
that seek him with a whole heart
the law
and the testimony
the law referred to is the Torah the
first five books of the Bible which
includes the Commandments and they will
be highlighted in this Psalm as well
so blessed are they that have the law
and the testimony the testimony is the
word of the prophets
throughout the Bible
that's the testimony because they
testified to the accuracy and the
correctness and the fullness of the
Torah the law the first five books of
the Bible
so blessed are they and this prophetic
gift includes whatever a prophet said
whether he's part of the Canon or not
what holder said what the daughters of
Philip said what any Prophet said is
part of the testimony including the
testimony of the remnant that's it all
of it
blessed are you if you walk in the law
of the Lord blessed are they that keep
his testimonies
that is the issue to the law says Isaiah
and the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in them is there any mention of any of
this law on Mount Sinai no therefore
there's no light in it nothing no matter
how many candles they light it's still
Darkness that's why they have to light
it because there's only Darkness yes oh
that my way is verse 5 were directed to
keep thy statues then shall I not be
ashamed when I have respect unto all thy
Commandments this is the basis of what
we are reading here
it says in verse 11.
Thy word have i hidden mine heart that I
may not sin against thee the issue is
sin Martin
and the issue of sin has to do with
salvation because it cost the price
it cost the price of the Son of God so
all of these things are incredibly
important if we drop down to verse 32 it
says I will run the way of thy
Commandments when thou shalt enlarge my
heart
so when you understand God's principles
and his government and his Commandments
will it make you narrow and bigoted as
the Pope says or will it enlarge your
heart so a natural cause of you keeping
the Commandments is that you will love
your neighbor okay so verse 34 says give
me understanding
and I shall keep thy law yea I shall
observe it with my whole heart make me
to go in the path of like Commandments
for therein do I Delight
will you get a greater understanding
when you keep God's Commandments you'll
have a heart condition okay will it
include portions of humanity or all of
humanity that now all Christ died only
for a few right for all oh he died for
all isn't that interesting
verse 45 says and I will walk at Liberty
for I seek thy precept so is the is the
law binding you and narrowing your path
or is it liberating setting you free
my hands also verse for the ayat also
will I lift up unto thy Commandments
which I have loved and I will meditate
in thy statutes
so Martin it shifts from one sphere to
the other
verse 53 says
has taken hold upon me because of the
wicked that forsake thy law
so Martin when you see this kind of
thing and you see a new covenant that
has nothing to do with the Covenant of
God but is made with something that
cannot see smell or hear
it's horror it you must be horrified can
you take part in this sort of activity
now verse 71 is to me a very interesting
one or verse 70 the heart is as fat as
Greece but I Delight in thy law it is
good for me
that I have been Afflicted that I might
learn thy statutes
does God teach us something through the
Troubles of Life everyone is a lesson
okay now where does the most pain come
from in the world isn't it because of
transgression of the law
take marriage
infidelity in marriage does it cause
happiness or does it cause pain
what about any of the other Commandments
any
any of The Commandments being broken of
course are you going to be happy by
using stolen goods are you going to be
happy if you stab your neighbor in in
the back
you're never going to be happy Martin
so if we drop to 97 verse 97 oh how I
love thy law it is my meditation all the
day
thou through thy Commandments has made
me wiser than my enemies what do you
make of that
wisdom is bound up with the law and you
have the Ten Commandments that's it and
so God took them away because he wants
you to be unwise so how much wisdom do
you have in this in something like this
none zero zero
I have more understanding than all my
teachers for thy testimonies are my
meditation Martin if the remnant would
take that to heart they wouldn't be
sitting on Mount Carmel lighting little
candles and shouting for Joy they
wouldn't do that
I understand more
than the Ancients because I keep thy
precepts
I have refrained my feet from every evil
way that I may keep thy word I have not
departed from thy judgments for thou has
taught me
but how important is it that we let God
teach us the way and how does he teach
it he teaches us through the
Commandments okay
verse 105 this is the best known verse
in the whole of the Bible Thy word is
the lamp unto my feet and a light unto
my path do we not sing that song
Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and the
light I'm not going to sing I'm going to
chase everybody away you can have
requests now
but the fact of the matter is this is
where truth lies but this the Deep stuff
this is this
this food for the soul
and then if we go to verse 115 well
first 111 thy testimonies have I taken
as a heritage
for how long Martha forever ah
I test the minis that which the prophet
has said
they have predicted that this would
happen and we look right past it and
take part in it
or verse 115 depart from me e evil doers
for I will keep the Commandments of my
God
depart from me
any transgression of the law or making a
new covenant
that is not based on the law is
something that you want to depart from
verse 130 tells me that the entrance of
Thy word giveth light it giveth
understanding unto the simple you will
not be able to discern if you are not
rooted in the scriptures no wonder the
Jesuits call this a poisonous ASP it's
amazing if you take
the Commandments
can a child understand them everybody
can understand it
but why don't they want it because they
cling to sin
verse 165 it's another one of these
wonderful verses great peace
have they which love thy law and nothing
shall offend them
so no fear no anxiety nothing of this
nature what when you read this kind of
thing
great peace of they which love thy law
all thy Commandments are truth Martin
verse 151
Thou Art near O Lord and all thy
Commandments are truth if you want to
have truth then listen to what God Said
and not to what
some greeny had to say and if we bring
it back the truth shall set you free
we've just read earlier that the law
is liberating yes and the Commandments
are truth so the truth will set you free
so what'll set you free the truth the
Commandments and who is the embodiment
of the Commandment Christ I am the way
the truth and the life and thy word is
truth now look at this Psalm ends this
is amazing
verse 171 my lips shall utter praise
when thou has taught me thy statutes
in other words when will you really
honor God when you understand and take
up his statutes when did I change my
life
from a pagan atheist
occultist
to a Believer when you started
implementing The Ten Commandments when I
was confronted with the Ten Commandments
and saw myself as a sinner your mirror
and so it says over here in verse 172 my
tongue shall speak of Thy word for all
thy Commandments are
righteousness
verse 174 I have longed for thy
salvation O Lord and thy law is my
delight if you separate the law
from your religion you end up here
better if you separate the law from your
religion then you become a pagan
so a lot of Christianity Today is
nothing other than paganism I think
that's a very good some summarizing
that you've just put there you cannot
separate salvation from the law
so if you read verse 174 again I have
longed for thy salvation O Lord and thy
law is my delight verse 176 the final
verse says I have gone astray like a
lost sheep
seek thy servant for I do not forget thy
Commandments Martin
Martin
that's food
that's food for the soul
this is junk food this is what we have
to look upon with horror
so where are they heading and why is it
important for them to implement these
things it's about Authority that said
what is the law of authority
the fourth Commandment the fourth
Commandment
Psychology today
October 6 2022 resilience the Sabbath
and the planet
so what is resilience
resilience is about recovery recovery is
a physiologic phenomenon
the Sabbath a day of religious
observance and abstinence from work is
really much more than just the
abstinence from work in Devotion to a
god
it's interesting that he writes that
with a capital G when he says a god very
interesting the Sabbath included time
for rest time for feasting time for
communing time for spiritual connection
and time for faith
the concept of a Sabbath an assurance
that at least once a week we get to move
into safety
physiology to heal be healthy and well
is one of recovery and therefore
resilience
a Sabbath or sabbatical need not have a
religious connotation a secular Sabbath
is as valid as a religious one
spiritual connection and a sense of
faith can be found within safety with or
without the belief in the constructs of
a religion
as we give time to ourselves for a
Sabbath and sabbatical to build our
resilience we can also give time to our
planet for regeneration Rejuvenation
recovery and resilience so the point
here Martin
is that the Bible says that the mark of
the beast
will be in the forward or the hand
so if you have a spiritual connection
then you are convicted that it has a
spiritual meaning and therefore you
accept it then you receive the mark of
the beast if you have no spiritual
connection you are just doing it for the
sake of validity and getting
physiological or relief planet or the
planet
then you get it on your hand
because you're doing it without any
spiritual reason so can the secular
world and the religious World Unite on
this we've seen it now definitely okay
during the onset of the covid-19
pandemic we saw the amazing resilience
of our planet from just one month of
near total shutdown of human activity
so the planet got arrest Martin because
everybody was on lockdown
so humanity is the problem with the
problem and not the volcano
these concepts of resilience recovery
safety and a Sabbath are not based in
philosophy or religion but in physiology
and biology
so the body needs it right now when he
talks about a Sabbath I think he's
quoting the NIV there instead of these
Sabbath but let's leave it at that can
we create a cultural contagion a meme of
a respected secular Sabbath
dare we save ourselves with this
medicine of a day off
modern a secular Sabbath that sounds
like Sunday to me that's a secular
Sabbath because it's definitely not the
biblical one which is the seventh day
and in any case that will be perfect for
the secular world
to do it for whatever reason okay
climate change did the Pope ask for a
day yeah did he put it in lodato Sea yes
did he ask for implementation no he
actually commanded it all right he
commanded implementation of a respected
secular Sabbath
but what if it is a false Sabbath Martin
then it boils down not to the day but to
Authority that's it and let's end it
with that because whose authority is
Paramount in my life I just read in
Psalms 119 whose authority I am willing
to accept I'm not willing to accept the
authority of a usurper
who has a new set of Commandments a New
Covenant and a respected secular
Sabbath let's pray
Heavenly Father
the world is on a precipice
they're standing on ten high places
and they want to make a Carmel decision
which according to them must this time
around go the other way
but as for me and my house Lord
we want to go the way of the truth and
the life which can be only found in the
law and the testimony and the one who
embodies it Jesus Christ Our Lord and
Savior amen amen
thank you
[Music]